voici le seul cimetière musulman du
québec unique au pays avec sa clôture
qui sépare les défunts chiites et
sunnites
depuis son ouverture en 1993 entre une
voie ferrée et un pipeline les musulmans
ils sont enterrés selon le rituel
religieux et dans des tombes orienté
vers la mecque mais la communauté
musulmane québécoise s'est agrandi d'ici
cinq ans il n'y aura plus de place ici
c'est ce que prévoit mazen mograbi il a
été mandaté par les mosquées de brossard
et de saint-hubert pour acheter un
terrain et ouvrir un nouveau cimetière
musulman cela permettrait du même coup
d'amasser des fonds pour les activités
de l'école apprendre le coran nos
enfants rené les enfants solvimo besoins
de la mosquée de l'entretien ça va
jusqu'à femme depuis plus de deux ans
l'agent immobilier claude huart cherche
un terrain propice dans un vaste
périmètre au sud de montréal pour la
muslim welfare association qui chapeaute
les deux mosquées il a approché une
quinzaine de municipalités
multiplier les offres d'achat sans
succès les démarches ont toujours
un peu avortée par ce que il semble que
les municipalités
refusent
systématiquement
pourtant à huntingdon en 2013 le maire
de l'époque voulait ce projet de
cimetière il était prêt à vendre un
terrain de la ville alors vous voyez le
terrain prévu c'était vraiment l'autre
côté de la ligne d'arbre ici on avait
lille ou qu'ils devaient servir aussi
maintien avec le chemin d'accès qui
pensez y si on tournait à gauche et ça
se faisait le tout simplement oui
intérêt un clavier qui servait
absolument rien pu rapporter à la ville
d'angers l'importer absolument rien à
vie stéphane gendron y voyait un moteur
de développement économique
j'ai toujours cru en moi que
l'immigration maghrébine en particulier
est une immigration instruite qui
s'intègre facilement c'est un plus pour
une ville de huntingdon qui qui était
dévitalisées l'eau qui se meurt à petit
feu mais le projet s'est buté à
l'opposition de quatre conseillers
municipaux sur six c'était épouvantable
les choses que j'ai entendu derrière les
portes closes et même publiquement
pendant les séances du conseil
je sais même pas se dire non parce que
je veux pas encourager davantage
l'islamophobie et le racisme
mais le refus n'était basé que sur des
préjugés raciaux et religieux
l'agent immobilier renchérit avec
l'exemple de hinchinbrooke là non plus
les conseillers n'ont pas voulu ils se
sont dépêchés de voter un règlement qui
empêchait la municipalité de donner des
services
dedans funéraires ou dans terme à des
personnes qui sont qui proviennent de
l'extérieur de leur communauté
hajir à belkacem vient de fonder
l'association pour la sépulture
musulmane elle ne tient pas à un
deuxième cimetière réservé aux musulmans
elle préfère l'idée très française de
carré musulman d'un cimetière existant
je pense qu'une bonne chose de chercher
donc des cimes tient existence à ce qu
une très bonne chose ça démontre notre
notre intégration notre volonté de
de vivre ensemble et de mourir ensemble
aussi comme la majorité des membres de
sa communauté elle ne fréquente pas les
mosquées elle ne tient pas à les
enrichir d'autant plus que l'argent
recueilli à laval ne semble pas avoir
permis de bien entretenir le cimetière
musulman elle n'est pas conforme mais
n'est pas adéquat c'est pas comme ça
quand on monte un moment il est mal
gérée et il est tout à fait abandonné
son association a signé une entente avec
une entreprise funéraire qui lui
permettra de traiter les dépouiller de
les enterrer en respectant le rituel
musulman
mazel mograbi ou six a conclu un contrat
avec un cimetière de la rive sud faute
de mieux on l'a déjà pris comme un
système d on a un contrat avec les
autres pour régler les situations mais
ça n'aura pas pas de promettre des
choses l'argent quand ça peut nous
rapporter sur nos propres soutiens pour
le porte parole des mosquées de
saint-hubert et de brossard ce n'est pas
juste une question d'argent c'est aussi
une question de principe nos comptes et
ceux des canadiens des québécois
puissent se trouvent des payeurs des
tacles
mais ont le droit de choisir la place
pouchkine
s'enterrer avec toutes ces années vécues
le premier ministre couillard disait
récemment qu'il voulait établir des
liens avec la communauté musulmane mais
lorsqu'on arrive à des problèmes
concrets comme chez lui l'eau personne
ne veut mettre ses culottes puis prendre
la responsabilité de dire il faut
s'occuper de ce dossier le ou non du
premier ministre accuse réception du
courrier il y a deux mois et demi claude
huard s'est adressé au premier ministre
couillard dans l'espoir qu'il dénonce ce
qu'il qualifie d' impasse mais québec
refuse d'intervenir le gouvernement
promet une nouvelle politique
d'intégration qui va privilégie la
neutralité de l'état donc pas question
d'intercéder en faveur d'une communauté
religieuse pour l'implantation d'un
cimetière